tre 20 l'actualité à l'étranger avec
d'abord cette incroyable tentative de
sauvetage qui captive l'amérique du sud
et l'amérique tout entière 33 mineurs
vous le savez sont coincés sous terre
les uns sur les autres
depuis près d'un mois les opérations ont
commencé aujourd'hui mais elle ne
devrait pas aboutir avant la mi décembre
lionel feierstein ils sont fatigués mais
tiennent debout filmé hier matin grâce à
l'envoi d'une petite caméra
les 33 mineurs coincés à 700 m sous
terre garde le moral
j'envoie une pensé à ma femme que
j'adore à toute ma famille à mes cousins
maison que qui nous attendent on essaye
de s'organiser et charme aux collègues à
sa nourriture isme qu'il n'a pas encore
mangé sig et trouver là vous voyez on a
des boissons énergisantes au moins qu'on
est tous bien l'hydrater
c'est ce qu'on voulait les mineurs sont
confinés dans ses galeries où l'humidité
avoisine les 95 % et la chaleur 30
degrés il occupe une pièce de 50 mètres
carrés où il partage la nourriture
la plupart d'or sur les sièges des
camions de chantier situé dans
d'immenses qualités à l'extérieur du
local
le groupe s'est réparti les tâches
sécuriser les galeries charger les
batteries des lampes ou s'occuper de
l'infirmerie
hier pour la première fois en 24 jours
les mineurs ont pu parler à leurs
proches des conversations d'une minute
par radio téléphone
je suis contente je suis très contente
de l'avoir entendu et on apprend comment
va-t-il moyens il va bien il est en
forme pour soutenir le moral des mineurs
les autorités leur ont envoyé des
lecteurs mp3 consoles de jeux et
projecteur vidéo les films ont été
sélectionnés par des psychologues
côté santé des vaccins ont été descendus
dans ses tuyaux notamment contre le
tétanos la diphtérie et la grille
évidemment dans la mine les risques de
maladies respiratoires très élevé et
nous faisons tout notre possible pour
les prévenir
le groupe vient de quitter son premier
refuge pour une galerie plus sèches et
sécurisée d'une centaine de mètres
l'énorme foreuse de 38 tonnes doit
d'ailleurs commencer dans quelques
heures a creusé dans sa direction
un puits de secours de 702 m ensuite les
mineurs devront se glisser un par un
dans une nacelle mais ce travail
fastidieux pourrait durer deux à trois
mois
le chili cherche mais n'a toujours pas
trouvé d'autre moyen plus rapide de
sauver ces mineurs